the second game of this double header
the blue jays beating the rangers five
to nothing blue jays need a sweep and
they need steve and max to come out just
like hunjin ryu and throw up some zeros
just ideal weather and this one down the
first baseline and out there into right
field isaiah peddling for two the throw
is not in time
and kinder philippa with his 17th double
of the year and even though it looked
like the ball may have beat him you can
see the slide and let's see if the tag
got there it's hard to tell from there
look like that right hand may have
gotten in before the tag we'll find out
here in a little bit because the blue
jays are going to challenge this and is
he safe all right so izzy will pick up
the double kinder philanthropic second
with one out and here's adolesce garcia
here's the 2-2
and he got him swinging a miss at 95
matz rings him up two down so two down
down here's joey gallo 2-1 and a swing
and a bouncing ball out to second simeon
looks it over onto first and a nice job
by mats after the lead off double and
it's mike fulton as we talked about in
our open making his 19th start of the
season for the rangers two and eight
record era just over five
marcus simeon lines the first pitch that
he sees into left field for a base hit
boy simeon can some kind of turn on a
fastball when he is locked in can he one
two and a bouncer out towards second
simeon trying to run back to first and
he does well enough
to prevent a double play now here's
george springer
and he swings at the first pitch fly
ball shallow center field
and it's going to drop in in front of a
diving white bushet around the third on
a bloop single for springer nolas garcia
is their normal center fielder and he's
got exceptional speed i'm not sure if
white misjudged that see if they can
take advantage and get on the scoreboard
here in the bottom of the first tay
oscar hernandez
hernandez hits it deep to left field and
it's off the wall on the fly
the shed into score springer has to be
held at third in rbi double forte oscar
hernandez and an early one to nothing
lead
as the 2-0 is chopped towards the left
side not hit hard and the throw is not
going to be in time
brock hold the third baseman stumbling
as he made the throw
so springer will score hernandez to
third gritchik will reach
and it is two to nothing two runs in two
out the base is loaded now he's gotta
turn his attention alertis goriel jr
guriel went two for three with a couple
of infield hits in the first game
a long way to left for a grand slam
what a first inning for the blue jays as
they have put six runs up on the board
and putting the pain on the rangers
second career grand slam for goriel two
down in the bottom of the second and now
here is vladimir guerrero junior
as guerrero swings at the first pitch
drives it deep left field and go on
number 31 for vladi and it is seven to
nothing i'll tell you he is unbelievable
when he steps into that batter's box
he's got a plan he knows what he's
looking for he doesn't deviate from it
here's springer now
now george springer swings at the first
page back to back
number six for springer and it is eight
to nothing with the word that they're
coming back to toronto they felt like
there was a jolt through the clubhouse
of a field of momentum i'll tell you the
last few games this offense has really
taken that to another level well what a
good sign this is hernandez draws the
walk randall grichik had an infield hit
drove in a run in the first inning
richik gives one a ride and it's gone
and the beat goes on for the blue jays
randall bridshick with the third home
run of the inning
and it is 10 to nothing here in the
second my oh my they have
brought the home run sticks this
afternoon
game number two base hit for solo number
nine hitter is jason martin the left
fielder in the 01
a bouncer to the left side biggio has it
to second one and on to first double
play that'll be
five six three on the double play with
buchet making the turn
ground ball back to the mound nice play
by matt's underhand toss to guerrero and
the side is retired blue jays 10 rangers
nothing top fourth
there's a swing at a ground ball to
short one hopper to bechet on the first
in time two down two down at the base is
empty joey gallo swinging a miss he got
him he strikes out gallow a very
impressive fourth inning for stephen
mats steven matt's still on the hill
jonah hein in the box the swing and a
line drive right field base hit for
jonah high bridgeick to pick it up
solheim has his second hit of the series
here under the second two down for the
rangers
and the 01 is swinging a ground ball
towards third biggio's got it and across
the diamond and plenty of time to get
him as matt sails through another inning
progress and then some for stephen mats
effective efficient and now out of the
game rafael dolis will come in for the
30th time this season
swing and a miss as delise gets kind of
11 to chase one down that's why he can
be a valuable guy out of that pen if he
throws enough strikes two down and
here's adolescarcia doesn't have a hit
in the series
it doesn't look like he's going to get
one here as it'll be davis the center
fielder to make the catch and the side
is retired 10-0 going bottom six and
spencer patton comes on here in the
sixth inning offense been good the
swinging amish here on an elevated
fastball in
strikes out one away in the bottom half
of the sick here comes marcus simeon
here's a good looking hard slider swing
and a miss by simeon he strikes out so
two men are out here in the bottom half
of the sixth
spencer patton strikes out the side in
order
in the sixth nicely done last chance for
the rangers now coming up they need at
least 10. all blue jays in cruise
control really since the early innings
and on their way to sweeping a
doubleheader and potentially tabby
shutting out the rangers in both ends of
the double header swinging a miss says
saucedo strikes out gallo jonah heim
back to the man nice play by saucedo
heim retired and the blue jays are an
out away
there's a liner to center davis is there
that's your ball game and that's your
double header as the blue jays shut out
the rangers 10 to nothing and sweep the
double header the good times keep on
rolling and again tomorrow night the red
sox in buffalo this is going to get very
interesting very quickly blue jays this
one wasn't even close after the first
inning the guriel grand slam kicked the
door open
four more in the second inning and then
the pitching staff took it the rest of
the way